thank you to blinkist for supporting pbs
in the last episode we traced some of
the major influences of werewolf legends
back thousands of years in europe and
looked at how christianity and real
world tragedies positioned the wolf
shapeshifter as a demonic threat
fears that ultimately culminated in the
torture and execution of humans rumored
to be werewolves
there's usually a fine line between fact
and fiction when it comes to monsters
so when did the threat of werewolves
become something largely resigned to the
pages of fiction during the
industrialization urbanization and rapid
scientific advancement of the 19th
century the werewolf was increasingly
positioned as literary fantasy rather
than a real threat the werewolf slunk
back into antiquity a symbol of the past
but modern literature and the silver
screen reinvigorated the werewolf legend
most contemporary ideas and conceptions
of the werewolf became dominated and
driven by film and they still are
we've moved the werewolf from the realms
of mythology from tales of warriors and
witches to a pop culture icon
i'm dr emily zarka and this
is monstrum
given the large scope of the folklore
collection of brothers grimm it's not
surprising that their 1812 anthology of
german folklore includes the story of a
man who transforms into a werewolf using
a special belt
variations of the story became the most
common werewolf story in germany at the
time
the popularity of the grimm brothers
publications helped launch the werewolf
into mainstream literature the first
werewolf in a 19th century novel appears
around the time of the grim tales 2 in
an 1824 historical romance titled the
albagensis written by irish gothic
novelist charles robert maturin and set
in the 13th century a character within
the text wakes from a nightmare to find
himself under attack by a lycanthrope
with fiery eyes white fangs and claws
who was in a horrid frenzy
later the attacker confesses i am a
fangles wolf a wolf man although he says
his fur grows on the inside the gothic
genre continued to evolve alongside and
influence the pulpy penny dreadfuls
cheap volumes of weekly serialized
sensational and violent stories the
perfect place for the first savage
werewolf transformation first serialized
as a penny dreadful and published as a
collected text in 1847 wagner the
werewolf is often considered the first
english text to have a werewolf as its
main character
set in germany it opens with a
mysterious man offering the elderly
wagner the chance to be young and
handsome again to have great fortunes
and intelligence to rival his riches but
there are two conditions the old man
must be the stranger's companion for a
year and a half and he must prey upon
the human race as a werewolf wagner
accepts the offering and drinks the
contents of a small vial the stranger
provides him he loses consciousness but
upon waking the old man is not only
young but preternaturally healthy and
intelligent
it is later revealed that the deal he
made was with john faust and wagner is
now immortal but must turn into a
werewolf once a month and the
description of that change is intense
convulsing horribly and shrieking
wagner's body elongates from its human
form into one of savage and brute-like
shape
his beautiful clothes become rough
shaggy and wiry skin and with a howl of
misery he becomes a monstrous wolf after
the mid 19th century werewolf accounts
in literature were often presented as
some kind of backward or strange local
value of the lower class and the
creatures were dismissed by rational
explanation an example this is found in
the first academic study of werewolves
in the english language sabine
beringuald's 1865 book of werewolves
account of a terrible superstition
the anglican priests folklore collection
claimed that while werewolf legends were
present across all nations they could
all be explained as real cases of human
violence that inspired monstrous
behavior usually cannibalism brought on
by madness the book did collect werewolf
tales from a variety of historical and
folkloric sources serving as a werewolf
anthology of sorts and while science and
religion continued to try to explain
away these stories people's appetite for
salaciousness and escapism wasn't going
anywhere the creature's variations
inspired fresh narratives like the
introduction of the seductive female
werewolf in the late 19th century
stories of female werewolves with white
fur appeared the attacks of these white
she wolves correspond to the sudden
appearance of a beautiful young stranger
this woman's real werewolf identity is
often indicated when in her human form
by her unusual eyes and penchant for
wearing white fur many stories like the
white wolf of castoption the werewolf
and the other side solidified the
presence of the female werewolf in
horror another beautiful and sexually
threatening creature contributing to the
already established role of
supernaturally monstrous women in gothic
literature at the turn of the century
mostly as a result of increased
attention towards psychology werewolves
became more associated with the idea of
a beast within a hidden illness or
monstrous personality concealed by a
veneer of civility
they also reverted back to being almost
exclusively male the reason for this is
the more frequent depiction of female
victims starting with richard baggett's
novel a roman mystery in 1899
which detailed a male werewolf's lured
attack on his sister-in-law the helpless
woman attacked by the sexually
aggressive wolfman proved to be a
popular take in penny dreadfuls pulp
magazines and novels and eventually film
i talked with horror critic and
journalist megan navarro to learn more
about how the werewolf's legacy was
shaped by the movies movies definitely
changed the werewolf in popular
imagination but werewolf legends from
centuries ago were often based around
like serial killers that terrorized the
land um the beast of verdun or the
werewolf of dole these were based on men
that were serial killers and slaughtered
and folklore was a means of exploring
and understanding those acts by
transforming them into literal monsters
movie depictions internalized that it
put the murderer
and the unwitting accomplice into one
body fighting for control in a way it
made that all about an internal battle
so it it has uh an inherently tragic
nature about that even with the
thousands of years of european lore to
draw from the first werewolf movies
instead appropriated and bastardized the
legends of the indigenous peoples of
north america the first motion picture
to feature a werewolf is the 1913 silent
film the werewolf we only know about
cinema's first werewolf from movie
reviews and historical documents the
film was destroyed by a massive fire at
universal studios in 1924 in the film a
dna woman marries a white man
after he is killed she is led to believe
he abandoned her and in anger she
becomes a witch and raises their
daughter to hate white men the daughter
grows up and leads a revolt against a
group of friars for safeguarding the
jealous white man who killed her lover
during the confrontation she turns into
a wolf after being shown a crucifix the
following year in 1914 the white wolf
again borrowed from a skewed perception
of indigenous legend the film portrays
another scorned lover this time an
indigenous medicine man who demands the
hand of a woman who does not return his
affections with the help of her lover
the medicine man is caught in his wolf
form and transforms back into a human
alas we don't know exactly how the
transformation is depicted since this
film too has been lost to time both
films clearly demonized non-white
populations a theme that permeated many
american horror films of the early 20th
century these horror and werewolf films
were made in the shadow of federal
policies that persecuted indigenous
populations including the seizing of
their native lands and the establishment
of mandatory christian boarding schools
the earliest surviving werewolf film is
wolfblood released in 1925 it is the
first known depiction of a white
werewolf in north america on screen
although it has left the audience to
decide if he really is a wolf
shapeshifter or suffering from clinical
lycanthropy in it a man living in a
remote logging camp receives a
life-saving blood transfusion from a
tame female wolf after the successful
procedure rival loggers are killed in a
wolf attack and rumors begin to swirl
that the lupine blood in the man's veins
transformed him into a werewolf
distraught by the accusation and haunted
by dreams of running with a pack of
wolves the man tries to kill himself
other early 20th century films
contribute significantly to the modern
whale with canon the werewolf of london
which is the first on-screen depiction
of a werewolf's bite transforming
another human into a werewolf the
werewolf of london is universal studios
first foray into werewolf films in the
movie east asia is the source of the
werewolf curse the main character
botanist dr glendon is bitten in tibet
by a werewolf while collecting a rare
flower under the full moon
ironically he is told by fellow botanist
dr yokami played by a scottish actor in
yellowface who tells dr glendon that the
flower is the only thing that can cure
his werewolf curse glendon rampages
through london in wolf form and
discovers that yogami is the werewolf
that bit him and the two werewolves
fight glendon prevails but survives only
long enough to be shot by scotland yard
and transform back into his human body
as he takes his final breath 1935 lacked
the special effects technology to turn
an actor into a realistic looking wolf
so the werewolf of london created a
hybrid man-wolf monster with
predominantly human features although
much hairier
scholars read this film as a
representation of repressed
homosexuality a warning against the
potential dangers of scientific
advancement the uncontrolled spread of
infectious disease and the growing fear
of the east asian population in the
western world the film hit theaters the
same week as bella lugosi and boris
karloff films
and the werewolf of london was quickly
overshadowed by the already popular
monsters a vampire and frankenstein's
creature
but luckily universal didn't give up on
the werewolf genre quite yet a few years
later universal introduced the wolf man
in a series of films leading to another
werewolf surge
in part because the journey of the
titular wolf man across europe
paralleled the movement of allied
soldiers in world war ii dr kyle frank
who i also talked to in the first
episode had this to say about the
wolfman film now the plot of the wolfman
from 1941 is particularly interesting to
me because of the traits and the traits
that it brings about that still retain
today and how we understand the modern
idea of the werewolf
so we start with lon chaney jr a rather
hapless american coming over to wales in
order to inherit his family seat
oh i remember you
that night
and in the crypt
go inside
traveling characters recur again and
again again as vehicles of the
supernatural whether that's because they
have a certain amount of knowledge that
the rational western mind does not have
or whether that's because they
themselves are infected or monstrous in
some way now it's particular that i use
the term infected because a
transformation is due to a bite and of
course we now understand that werewolves
transform because you get bitten and you
get infected and then become a werewolf
and sure enough we have lon chaney jr
transforming at a full moon which again
is a real trope that we see in
werewolves today
but also not just that not being aware
of what he's done now although he isn't
killed by a silver bullet he's beaten to
death um by his father as it happens
there is an element of tragedy there
they simply can't control what they are
doing
and so
again when we look at texts nowadays
although the death of the beast the
destruction of the violent animalistic
trait the violent animalistic monster is
necessary it's not always met with
absolute happiness there is a question
of whether we ourselves could find
ourselves guilty of things that we're
not aware that we're doing the release
of the first of these films in 1941
featured the more enduring human-looking
werewolf interpretation
they were likeable characters
that became the villains in their own
stories uh through often no fault of
their own
that set them apart it was a
transformation of successful people
to varying degrees unraveling thanks to
unwanted and terrifying changes in their
own body
that makes them more relatable than your
average movie monster and then on top of
that you have
remarkable makeup effects in both cases
of the werewolf london and the wolf man
jack pierce did both of those makeups
and it brought that internal battle that
loss of control to the forefront it
crystallized the tragic horror
uh it gave it a visual
like a more textual approach through
through seeing that transformation in
history real monsters appropriate the
ones we talk about here
after world war one soldiers in the
german military who refused to disband
at the end of the war joined together
under the moniker werewolf
the unit would go on to become an elite
nazi recruiting source in world war ii
werewolves were consciously integrated
into the nazi party borrowing from older
german myths to create propaganda that
reflected hitler's notorious obsession
with the supernatural and the occult
he even used wolf as a pseudonym for
himself as world war ii came to an end
the nazis launched multiple campaigns
inspired by the lupine beast
in 1944 they developed operation
werewolf a mass poisoning plot that was
never successfully implemented although
declassified documents from the national
archives in britain show that the
supplies of american and british troops
were targeted then in 1945 a werewolf
forces unit was created with the intent
of putting volunteer german fighters
secretly behind enemy lines these nazi
werewolf operations would not be
examined in fiction until much later
the real and lasting effect of the
horrors of the nazi regime made that
impossible with the end of the war and
the new atomic era a timely werewolf
appeared the scientifically created
nuclear experiment werewolf in 1956
moviegoers were introduced to the human
to wolf transformation caused by
irradiated wolf blood in the werewolf
adding nuclear experimentation into the
werewolf cannon
other anxieties of the decade were
explored in i was a teenage werewolf
often read as a commentary on the fear
of increasing juvenile delinquency
in the movie a troubled and violent
teenager tony becomes a werewolf after a
hypnotherapist injects him with an
experimental serum
the movie was a massive success
particularly with young adult audiences
a new post-war economic power
this movie is arguably the first ever to
cater specifically to the teen
demographic although certainly it would
not be the last in fact since the 1950s
many narratives containing werewolf
characters from teen wolf to gingersnaps
harry potter to twilight have aimed for
a teenage audience in 1964 television
saw its first small screen and comedic
werewolf in the character of eddie
munster
another popular horror comedy series
dark shadows also included werewolves
further expanding the monster's
influence as its small screen
representations engage new audiences and
for the first time made werewolves funny
werewolf films of the 1960s and 70s were
dominated by narratives that depicted
rising countercultures the dismantling
of the nuclear family and even the
corruption behind the watergate scandal
globally werewolf films of the 70s took
on changing sexual politics in parallel
to the growing sexual revolution
with plots featuring promiscuous female
victims and murderous prostitutes the
advancement of special effects and a
growing appreciation for its artistry
helped birth the violent transformation
scenes that would become a hallmark of
werewolf films in the 1980s
the audience's fascination with the
grotesque change from human to werewolf
also corresponds to growing stigmas
around changes in the body that could
occur with aging fitness and diet 1980s
werewolf films also took up ideas of
class showing that idealized suburbs
were not the safe havens governments and
popular media portrayed them to be the
1981 film the howling loosely adapted
from a 1977 book depicts an entire
resort full of werewolves it became
inherently more terrifying
in the idea that it wasn't just one
werewolf slash serial killer stalking uh
protagonist karen white
she
finds herself in the lion's den so to
speak of an entire werewolf colony she's
isolated and trapped and those she loves
most are also becoming werewolves around
her so
that was a pretty big push forward into
expanding you know beyond one werewolf
you have werewolves the movie was
groundbreaking for its use of special
effects makeup showing the full
transformation from man to beast rob
boutine's close-up transformation with
the bladder effects it just not only
added a layer of like creepiness and
made this villain even just more
intimidating but there's
something very painful about that too it
brings a physicality to the dual nature
of being a werewolf special effects
makes being afflicted with lycanthropy
something hair like harrowing and
terrifying
it captures the body horror of what that
means to become a werewolf in this very
impressive way also released in 1981 an
american werewolf in london borrows from
european werewolf lore and references
historical explanations for the monster
after being wounded by a werewolf the
main character david deteriorates
mentally as the full moon waxes the film
alludes to a demonic cause behind the
original werewolf transformation a
metaphorical inner beast and even a
vision david has of mutant nazi
werewolves drawing supernatural nazi
werewolves into the horror movie genre
for the first time the werewolves
dramatic presence continued steadily
into the 1990s 18 movies with a myriad
of werewolf characters were released
during the decade including a modern
take on the werewolf lover myth
arl stein's goosebumps series alone
included eight werewolf stories between
1995 and 1999. buffy the vampire
slayer's lovable oz fought alongside the
slayer proactively caging himself during
the full moon the 1990s marked the
popularity of the werewolf in another
form of media video games while 1988's
altered beast holds the title for the
first video game with a werewolf
character games of the 90s fully
embraced and embellished the monster
hungry audiences demanded more and
werewolf popularity skyrocketed ushering
in a renaissance the monster hadn't seen
in centuries and the growing werewolf
obsession really reached its pinnacle
with alvin and the chipmunks meet the
wolfman
kidding it's terrible i'm really talking
about the canadian film gingersnaps
released in 2000 ginger snaps both
honors and transforms the previous two
decades of werewolf cinema the film
explicitly portrays werewolfism as a
sexually transferable condition and
directly relates female puberty to
monstrosity both first for the monster
it's freaking awesome i think that a lot
of the modern werewolf owes
a debt to
gingersnaps
that movie opened up the possibility of
what a werewolf stool nature could mean
it's no longer just a man fighting off
his inner beast or resisting his darker
impulses or you know trying to fight off
a desire to kill
now it can be a woman experiencing the
changes that come with puberty it could
be an exploration of burgeoning
sexuality it could be an exploration of
aging mortality even the story set in a
seemingly idyllic suburb of toronto
follows teen goth sisters ginger and
bridget
ginger is bitten by a werewolf
triggering a transformation directly
linked to her menstrual cycle the film
addresses teenage self-mutilation
suicidal thoughts and violence at school
a plot point that came under scrutiny
since its release followed the 1999
columbine and w r myers high school
shootings
the movie also addresses mental illness
in young adults which came front and
center in the 1990s as psychiatric drugs
were increasingly prescribed to minors
the film's 2004 sequel would go on to
address drug addiction through the
werewolves dependence on intravenous
treatment to curb her transformation and
violent desires in 1999 jk rowling used
a professor lupin werewolf character as
a metaphor for illnesses with social
stigmas like hiv the werewolf also
continued to reflect real world anxiety
when post-9 11 we saw an increase in
narratives featuring military and
werewolf conflicts using werewolf lore
to explore themes like ptsd corrupt
military officials secret government
weapons and even the war on terror long
removed from real accusations of
witchcraft and theological discourse the
21st century produced more werewolf
interpretations than
ever seen before
vampire werewolf hybrids jughead as a
werewolf magical werewolf hides that
contain eternal werewolf spirits
werewolf sims packs of cartoon werewolf
pups aggressively muscular werewolves
the list goes on
it seems like werewolves haven't been
this talked about since the werewolf
trials
in regard to twilight stephanie mayer
does something that we have seen done
time and time again
and that is the misappropriation of
native american culture which is
entwined with folklore about or beliefs
in or narratives of werewolves to give
them a certain authenticity although the
way the mayor uses this is
very problematic it's incredibly racist
it makes all sorts of assumptions i
think what it also does is it shows us
something
mayor did not invent this it shows us
something that has been occurring for a
long time this shows how
settling cultures or colonizing cultures
have absorbed they have misappropriated
they have cannibalized indigenous
beliefs in order to give a veneer of
authenticity to new narratives
on screen teen wolf true blood vampire
diaries hemlock grove van helsing and
penny dreadful showed audiences
attractive werewolves battling other
supernatural creatures and coming to
terms with their true nature but not all
modern werewolves inspire nsfw fan
fiction
with so much history shadowing the
werewolf i wanted to know what creating
a new story looks like today so i asked
olivia stevens graphic novelist and
comic writer who just released a new ya
werewolf graphic novel artie and the
wolf moon i think it's important to
start this off by saying that i am not a
traditional werewolf fan i'm more or
less a blasphemous
world enthusiast and a lot of my
enthusiasm for werewolves isn't built
from the werewolf media consumed but
built off of my interest in wolves as an
animal
so for me werewolves represent a deep
relationship with nature
given the essential role that wolves
play in their ecosystems and so i see
werewolves as an opportunity to kind of
showcase
uh achieving balance and reciprocity
between humanity and nature and i also
see werewolves as sort of this vehicle
for family and community building these
werewolf stories demonstrate another
modern werewolf trend the werewolf pack
the pack is often portrayed as a
tight-knit community often at war with a
rival pack or engaged in conflict with
another supernatural species the
importance of the pack and of community
for survival is present in real wolf
populations and human ones as well
providing ample material for
supernatural metaphor and i structured
the narrative so that while
it is ultimately a story about
werewolves and vampires it also isn't
it's about a lot of things
these figures
um are so often used as symbols and
storytelling to represent something else
so that tension between a clan of
werewolves that are black due to their
origins as escaped slaves being under
threat by a coven of largely white
vampires who use hypnosis and other
means to target vulnerable members of
that community and so distrust and
paranoia within that community that
is a mirror to the real world um of the
story in a number of ways so within this
reading vampirism is uh representative
of white supremacy and white supremacy
uh as a death cult
so
uh it's an ideology whose members seek
to one
destroy inter-community relationships
to to burden and drain the marginalized
and three to not even appear to place
much value in their own lives
which is why they take so little stock
in the lives of others
and refuse to acknowledge our
interconnectedness as people in the last
decade we've seen plenty of comedic
werewolves we don't smell our own
crotches we smell each other's cartoon
werewolves and grotesque werewolves as
well we've seen more than 50 films and
countless books and comics for audiences
of all ages featuring werewolf
characters and there's no indication
that the trend is slowing down in fact
it's the opposite but where will
werewolves take us next i'm looking
forward to
uh tenderness
i'm excited for tender and sensitive
werewolves basically
anything that spits in the face of the
tortured
violent wolf man losing control
as we become more aware about wolves but
also about our relationship with the
natural world and what systems might be
the real monsters in all of this
i just want to see how far we can
collectively stretch
this very intriguing concept
before it just snaps i think olivia is
on to something in the last 10 years
real world reports of werewolf sightings
have increased beginning in 2015 the
british press ran stories about old
stinker the beast of barmston drain a
wolf with a human face and terrible
breath who seemed to only terrorize
women and the occasional dog but this
was not his first appearance
in the 1960s he appeared nearby in
flixton as an ancient wolf-like creature
walking upright with an unusually long
tail he would knock people over with
this resurgence of werewolf sightings in
great britain is particularly strange
given the country's general lack of
werewolf folklore since wolves have long
been absent from england how do we
explain the recent sightings of the
werewolf known as old stinker are pop
culture and broader distribution of
movies literature video games and
internet lore the inspiration behind
this 21st century werewolf
well only partially the place where old
stinker has been spotted an area called
hull also happens to be the last
reported habitat of wolves in england
using an eco-gothic lens we can perhaps
offer other alternatives to what the
werewolf can give us what this hybrid
monster can show us is that being both
is not scary it is a great opportunity
for us to understand what humanity and
what wulftum means and what these
identities can offer for a long time
wolves have been symbols of the ravaging
and rapacious wilderness and then more
recently they have been reclaimed as
pure and perfect symbols of this
wilderness that must necessarily remain
untouched by human hands i think that
werewolf gives us a place to think not
with these two extremes good versus evil
but to think about how the truth of both
our own existence as humans and those
wolf's existence is that it's somewhere
in between and that we find ourselves
living in a world that is not
wilderness versus culture but always
somewhere muddling along between the two
real or fiction good or evil man or
beast
ultimately werewolves are about
dichotomies they represent the thin
boundaries between the human and inhuman
interior motives and outward appearance
animal and man wild and civilized as the
perception of these contradictions
changes over time so too does the
werewolf the
best werewolf movie in the last 10 years
and luckily it has been a nice exciting
boon for werewolf in in horror but uh
the best one might be 2017's good
manners writer directors juliana rojas
and marco dutra they use the werewolf
mythology to explore loneliness and
classism of motherhood and the horrors
of pregnancy and all of it is just
gels into this really grim fairy tale
style narrative structure that's
both scary and beautiful and i think
that that kind of speaks to what defines
the modern werewolf and that there
really isn't any definition anymore
other than the core of someone
transforming into wolf or wolf creature
i'm hopeful that in the future we're
going to see more positive
man-in-to-wolf transformations the other
thing i'd absolutely love to see is far
more texts where werewolves live
alongside vampires and fairies and they
live alongside sea monsters and zombies
for me that reflects more truly what it
is like living in an intersectional and
diverse society and a society where we
can be connected with the pluralism via
the internet and that these monsters
these creatures that come from specific
identities and cultures have to learn
how to live alongside each other much
like we are doing today we've come a
long way from the first rumblings of the
werewolf in ancient european cultures
and thankfully just as far from the
persecution of humans as werewolves but
what we haven't lost is the fear and the
freedom in the human capacity for
dramatic change
we'd like to thank blinkist for
supporting pbs it can be hard to find
the time to sit down and read a whole
book but now you can in the blink of an
eye
blinkist is an app that produces key
takeaways from thousands of non-fiction
books and condenses them into 15 minutes
that you can either read or listen to
blinkist has an array of categories to
suit many interests from society and
culture to history and philosophy for
more information and a blinkist limited
trial please go to the link in the
description
okay my eyelash is kind of coming off
you can't tell right
no just the corner of this eye
perfect
okay